hahaha
[Music]
the last post for their Queen before the
first visit from their King
Northern Ireland's first Minister
designate Shin fein's Michelle O'Neill
will offer the Monarch her condolences
and that's gone down well on Shankle
Road where they don't come more loyal to
the crown we were devastated when we
heard of her possum and I think the
amount of flage reflects how much
Stacey Graham is a community worker here
with Queen epitomized for me everything
it meant to be British but she also knew
how important it was to put that hand
don't reach that hand out to
dad if he saw that when she met Martin
McGinnis we saw that when she went to
the Republic of Ireland and spoke an
Irish
it was during her State visit that the
queen used the native language
Argus akoisa
when she went on the state visit that
was a game changer it was something
she'd always wanted to do Lord brookebra
a friend of the royal family says the
queen built Bridges it was that smile
and she you very ever sort of saw her
talking to somebody in a crowd or by
arranged meeting when she didn't have
this lovely smile and her twinkle in her
eye what was your last contact with the
late Queen what will be your final
memory of her we were privileged to be
at Windsor for two nights during Royal
Ascot this year when we were saying
goodbye to her as we were turning to go
away she said I do hope things will be
better in Northern Ireland soon
the new King has already gone further
than his mother to heal Old Wounds
visiting Malik Moore where the IRA
killed his great uncle and father figure
Lord mountbatten by detonating a bomb on
his fishing boat
she shook hands with Martin McGinnis a
former Ira Commander
but he's shaken hands with Jerry Adams
the world's most recognizable Irish
Republican
Lady Mary Peters who won Olympic gold 50
years ago has many personal memories of
Queen Elizabeth
warms love friendship
and her love of Northern Ireland and
she's confident King Charles will also
be able to bring people together here he
writes a lot of personal letters which
I've had the privilege of reading and I
think he'll do it differently but he has
had a long term of training from his
mother and I think he'll do it very well
long live the king
history will record the Queen's
contribution to peace and that
responsibility now rests on the
shoulders of the king
David Blevins Sky News in Belfast